hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round five of the gush team of
Memorial 2018
well not another game since this is the
first game I'm showing you from round 5
the previous one was from Round 4 that
nice victory of the powerful versus mama
DRF but here again we have an
interesting game where cousin already on
move 5 goes completely out of book and
plays a move that is that isn't found in
any database or so they say
and it's a very very interesting game
and well you'll just have to see it and
it did prepare the final standings not
the final the standings after round 5 so
I do hope I remember to show you those
after I show you the game so Carson
opens with E 4 we have C 5 and now
Knight to c3 so okay this isn't weird I
mean it is a bit weird so far any game
I've seen cross in place against the
Sicilian he will go for the usual Knight
to f3 so maybe he maybe he just doesn't
want to show Caruana what his plans
against the Sicilian are you know being
all secretive for November we have d6
and now d 4 nonetheless C capture some
before Queen captures on d4 and Knight
to c6 and here usually you will see
either Queen to d3 or you'll see Bishop
to b5 and maybe after Bishop to d7 only
then Queen to d3 but cross and
immediately retreats the Queen to d2 and
it's a quite a weird move you know
you're blocking your dark square bishop
so obviously you will develop at some
point but now it's very interesting how
you will do it so let's see how Carlsen
does it a nice to f6
we have b3 obviously going to fianchetto
the bishop
we have east 6 and Bishop to b2 a6
queenside castle and b5 voice check is
now preparing his expansion on the Queen
side hoping for Queen to a5 and start
pushing his pawns on the Queen side
f3 solidifying d4 pawn and now H 5 H 5
is a is a weird move to say the least
and I haven't seen any I I don't think
there was a like an interview after the
game or something
but I couldn't really find any ideas
behind the h5 move maybe
after 92 to g3 maybe to kick the night
away from g3 or maybe just to grab more
space on the kingside maybe it's some
some attractive way of of maybe
developing this rook but a very strange
move and crossing it seems Carlson
immediately takes advantage of it he
goes nice to h3 and next he will put the
Knight to g5 since the point is already
on h5 there is no h6 move that can kick
away the night
Bishop to e7 and now Knight to g5
immediately we have a CH for grabbing
even more space here and now f4 by
Carlsen Bishop to b7 we have King to be
one doesn't want his King on this
diagonal this bishop can always cause
cause some trouble if the Queen and King
are on the same diagonal and also it
will be useful in the future and that's
the be under C C file when the rook
comes to c8 so rook to c8 now we get
Bishop to e2 and now Queen to c7 rook
h2e 1/9 to h7 and this is was well it's
it's kind of the critical position of
the game all of the pieces are developed
by both sides this rook okay it's not
yet developed but this pawn is already
on h4 so it's like the rook is developed
on the H file and it took a voice check
some the over 30 minutes to play his
next move he played nice to h7 he wants
to exchange pieces here and well when
you're down on space you want to trade
pieces so nice captures we have rook
captures on h7 and g4 by Carlsen H
captures and g3 on Poisson we have h
captures and g3 and Bishop to f6 now all
of Voyager X pieces are now eyeing that
a queen side of Carlson's Bishop to d3
x-raying that rook on h7 a rock to h8
and now g4
we have night the d4 and rook to e3 King
to f8 King to f8 a very important move
because what district wants to play
Queen to if a five at some point but he
can never do this while the king is on e
it because now cousin would would have
this well-known idea of Knight captures
on b5 and now after
capture somebody do you have another in
between move of knife captures and d6
that comes with check
so after King to d7 now you would
capture the Queen and after let's say
rock to h1 check again and in between by
black Bishop to c1 King finally
capturing the knight now you had a five
this comes with check you attack the
bishop and after a couple of more moves
king b2 unpinning
cousin would be up upon after all after
this little skirmish so not to allow
this first King to f8 now there will be
no night b-52d 6 or or any other
in-between checks ideas Knight to e2
cousin offers a trade of knights Knight
captures rook captures and Bishop to c3
Bishop captures and b2 was also an idea
but both moves are are fine for black we
have Bishop captures Queen captures and
Queen to e3 and so not not all that easy
to find a plan for black as you can see
cousin did a very nice job not allowing
this rook to infiltrate by any any rank
so rook to c5 we have E 5 now D captures
F captures and rook to h1 this rook to
h1 move is basically the move that loses
the game for voice check here you should
have continued rook to d5 kind of
pinning it as Bishop not allowing it to
move maybe maybe pile up maybe go even
maybe even well nothing to e7 Queen g5
will always be nasty but you know Rock
d5 a nice move waiting waiting for calls
and to play something but after this F
captures only five he played rock to h1
and this is basically the move that
loses the game cross and plate rook
captures we have Bishop captures and now
rock to h2 this comes with an attack on
this Bishop and also threatens the rope
to h8 rook captures on e5
you can't capture with the Queen then
simply rook captures on h1 so rook
captures the queen is attacked but now
comes rock to h8 check King t7 and now
Queen to a7 check and it was actually in
this position that rather Slovak
resigned the game it might be might be a
weird decision to
resign a game in a position like this
you're so close to checkmate if rookie
one can only be played this would be
checkmate but what I calculated
precisely and whatever whatever he plays
here we'll lose we'll lose immediately
he doesn't really have mana a lot of
options he can go King f6 or King d6 he
can also give up the bishop but that's
kind of pointless so let's see what
happens if you go skim to d6 if King to
d6
it's actually mating five rogue d8 check
King moves now Queen captures a6 check
King c7 now Queen to d6 check King b7k
rook b8 check King g7 and now Queen to
b6 this will be checkmate but it's a lot
more interesting after this Queen a7
check what if he goes King to f6 now
you're welcome to pause the video here
and try to continue this attack for
white it's quite an interesting
continuation to the attack so feel free
to do so or if maybe you don't want to
maybe you just want to enjoy the show
let's see what would happen how well the
move of course you have to find is g5
forcing either the king or the rook to
capture it if rook captures then simply
rook captures on h1 the rook is away
from the e-file there is no more rook e1
checkmate so obviously after g5 you have
to capture with the King as the King can
go to the King can't go to e7 and the
light squares are covered by the bishop
so after King capture some g5 now you
have Queen to e7 check and you can
either block with the pawn or you can go
King to f4 if you go King to f4 then you
get Queen h4 check King moves Queen g3
check King moves now comes Queen f2
check King moves and now again you got
the king to the D file Ruby a check King
moves look c8 check King moves and now
you grab the Queen and you black loses
the game but after this Queen to e7
check black can also block with this f6
f6 move but if if he plays that then
Queen captures and g7 check King moves
rook h4 check King III Queen g1 check
now King D 2 and Queen to C 1 this will
again be checkmate so after a single of
this avoid a shock so that whatever he
plays
everything will result in checkmate and
he decided to resign the game here so
this is a cross since first victory in
this tournament it only happened in
round five and it's very interesting
here I do have the the standings after
round five in first place we have
Veselin Topalov as he won another game
also in round five against Navi navara
so as you can see calls him in second
place and casamento Paulo are the only
two players that actually won want at
least one game all of the other all of
the other players have either drawn all
their games or lost some of the games
but that's those are the standings T'Pol
of course an onigiri in third
then tomorrow job of Rothman of Sergey
Carrick ending Liron shocking our
material avoid a second David navara
those three in the last last three
places that have lost at least one game
so it's a very very tough tournament and
I did hear the ding leerin versus
onigiri was was quite an interesting
game in round 4 that thing mr. Winn so
maybe maybe I'll maybe I'll check it out
and see if it's worth showing
hope it hope it will be but until then
we'll see I will check up some out some
other games and the feel free to use
hashtag suggestions to suggest some of
the games you like in the comments there
are a lot of suggestions so I can't show
all of them but I will I will see all of
your suggestions you don't have to worry
about that and at some point you know
while I'm browsing through the
suggestions I will show your game so
yeah that's basically it I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to all
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
thank you all